All: Quake the pool.
Quake the pool.
That's called
"Quaking the Pool."
It's the latest
summer challenge.
White people have been
quaking the pool since
they were the only ones
allowed in them.
Quake the pool.
Yeah, you get it.
But it's not just pools
that can be quaked.
You can quake anything.
all: Quake the bowl.
Quake the bowl.
- Yeah.
all: Quake the bowl.
Quake the tank.
Quake the cube.
[all shouting]
Aim for the Jaccuzzi, pussy!
Cannonball!
He went with a can opener!
Probably tore his gooch!
This video confirms two
stereotypes
White's can't jump, but
thankfully they can swim
I'd suggest wearing some aqua
socks next time
Some traction. I tried to jump
over my infinity pool
I am so (bleep) rich!
Mo Money Mo Problems!